قد سمعنا بخدمه عبور السيارات للاكل
والشراب ولكن هل سمعتم بهذه الخدمه
للجنازه نحن نوفر خدمات مختلفه للعائلات
يوضع الميت في التابوت في غرفه مع نوافذ
كبيره وهذا يسمح للناس بتقديم واجب العزاء
خلال العبور بالسياره كما تقول احد
الاعلانات على الموقع عندما لا تكترث
للنزول من السياره ولكن هذا ليس ما يقوله
المؤسس انه مصمم للناس ذوي الاعاقات التي
تمنعهم من النزول من السياره او اذا كان
الجو لا يسمح بالخروج ويضيف انه مع الدفع
لجنازه تقليديه تاتي خدمه عبور السيارات
مجانا هذه ليست اول مره نسمع فيها عن
جنازه مع خدمه عبور السيارات اذ ان مستودع
ادم للجثث يوفر خدمه العبور في السياره
للناس التي لا يمكنها الاقتراب من
الميت
cnn new
york